alles wäre jetzt fraktionsvorsitzender
der arzt die lage ist ernst
weltweit hat das corona virus 76 länder
erfasst und über 3.200 tote gefordert
93.000 infizierte sind aktuell
registriert in deutschland ist die zahl
der bestätigen infizierten mittlerweile
auf 258 gestiegen
wie viele menschen wirklich das virus in
sich tragen und weiterverbreiten weiß
niemand genau
der leiter der virologie der charité
warnt bis zu 70 prozent der deutschen
bevölkerung könnten sich anstecken
trotzdem gibt es bis heute keine
durchstrukturierte mit klaren
verantwortlichkeiten unterlegte corona
test infrastruktur wer aus einem
risikogebiet kommt und sich testen
lassen will wird auch von pontius zu
pilatus geschickt keiner fühlt sich
zuständig dieses chaos und dieses
kompetenz wirrwarr ist kein verhängnis
aus heiterem himmel
es ist die folge eines konkreten
politischen versagens und das ist ein
fahrlässiges spiel mit dem leben und mit
der gesundheit unserer bürger nach allem
vor allem was wir wissen geht von dem
virus eine höhere ansteckungsgefahr und
ein größeres mortalitätsrisiko aus als
von der gewöhnlichen grippe
eine erkenntnis die sie herr minister
sparen noch am 24 januar geleugnet haben
die infektion verlaufe bei corona bilder
haben sie gesagt das war nicht ihre
einzige fehleinschätzung leider am 27
januar haben sie überhaupt wir sind gut
vorbereitet sie tun es noch heute
vier wochen später am 26 februar haben
sie zugegeben wir befinden uns am beginn
einer cholera-epidemie passiert ist in
diesem entscheidenden wochen nichts
sie sind der meinung man müsse zeit
gewinnen für notwendige
präventionsmaßnahmen das hätten sie
längst in den vergangenen wochen tun
müssen
und anstatt sich eine eigene kompetenz
zu erarbeiten verstecken sie sich hinter
fach einschätzung nach dem es wasser und
seife zur bewältigung der krise auch
thesen erst jetzt in diesen tagen gibt
es einen krisenstab der plant maßnahmen
zur sicherung der versorgung mit
schutzausrüstung vorzubereiten
vor wochen hätte man das tun müssen nun
rächt sich auch das in ihrer
regierungszeit die letzte antibiotika
produktionsstätte in deutschland
schließen musste die versorgungslage mit
entsprechenden medikamenten
verschlechtert sich zusehends
die unruhe in der bevölkerung
wäre zweifellos weitaus geringer
wenn diese regierung einen kompetenteren
und ernsthafteren eindruck machte
und wenn die bürger das vertrauen haben
können dass ihre regierung sich um ihre
kernaufgaben kümmert und zwar den schutz
der bürger und die krisenprävention die
sie wochenlang sträflich vernachlässigt
hat die zeit drängt dabei sind die
folgen des umsetzungs und kommunikations
versagens schon nicht mehr einzuholen
statt rhetorischer beruhigungspillen
sind jetzt konkrete sofortmaßnahmen
nötig wir müssen die vorhandenen
behandlungskapazitäten laufend erfassen
und zügig erweitern um auf einen
schlagartigen anstieg der
erkrankungsfälle gewappnet zu sein
wie viele intensivbetten können
kurzfristig bereitgestellt werden wie
viele isolierstationen sind vorhanden
wie viele werden benötigt das muss
koordiniert werden
wir brauchen flächendeckende und
verpflichtende tests für risikopersonen
und menschen die an grippe oder schweren
erkältung erkrankt sind
nötig ist eine getrennte test
infrastruktur statt arztpraxen und
krankenhäuser mit untersuchungen und
versorgung allein zu lassen
von hausärzten und primärversorgung
praxen zu erwarten dass sie ohne den
erforderlichen schutz hilfe leisten
grenzt an fahrlässige körperverletzung
es müssen dringend fehlende
schutzausrüstung für ärzte und
medizinisches personal bereitgestellt
werden sonst wiederholen sich pannen wie
letzten sonntag in der charité hat seine
ganze notaufnahme schicht selbst in
quarantäne musste nachdem ein
verdachtsfall hoch positiv getestet
worden war
und das nachdem der patient nach hause
geschickt wurde
nötig sind auch temperatur kontrollen an
den flughäfen das wird in china gemacht
die freiwillig auszufüllenden fragebogen
auf die die bundesregierung setzt sind
leider wenig effektiv wir benötigen
systematischer einreise kontrollen an
den grenzen die die bundesregierung
leider bis heute ablehnt österreich kann
züge stoppen italien kann migranten
schiffe unter quarantäne stellen aber
deutschland lässt die grenzen und
kontrolliert was sie das witzig finden
müssen hier die ungelöste migration
die krise verschärft sich aktuell
dramatisch im nahen und mittleren osten
wütet das virus besonders heftig und
ausgerechnet jetzt setzt die türkei
10.000 begrenzen
von dort nach europa in marsch trotzdem
klammert sich die bundesregierung an das
dogma der offenen grenzen
diese starrsinnigkeit verschlimmert die
infektionsgefahr und kann leben kosten
und die üblichen lobbyisten der hof
weiter so schreien wieder ja rufen schon
danach alle kontrolliert aufzunehmen das
ist nicht nur weltfremd
das ist haarsträubend verantwortungslos
für besonders gefährdete
bevölkerungsteile ältere menschen person
mit mehrfach erkrankung müssen konkrete
schutzmaßnahmen ergriffen werden auch
sie müssen spüren dass sie ihren anteil
dazu beitragen können und auch müssen
wegen der eklatanten versäumnisse leider
bereits angesteckte personen rechtzeitig
zu identifizieren kann es zu einer
schlagartigen erhöhung der
krankheitsfälle kommen sehr geehrte
damen und herren das thema geht mir
persönlich sehr nahe
wir haben es mit einer echten krise zu
tun
die lässt sich nicht mit welkenden
kanzlerin post cast und beschwichtigung
sprüchen aller maß und mitte oder wir
sind gut vorbereitet weg schätzen
wo bleibt die strategie ich sehe
überhaupt gar keine wachen sie auf seien
sie bitte professionell befassen sie
sich mit den wahren problemen und
handeln sie wie es dem interesse dieses
landes und seiner bürger entspricht
dafür sind sie gewählt und wir stehen
dazu bereit sie dabei zu unterstützen
vielen dank so und man merkt die
aussprache zum kurs hat angefangen
während in spa noch davor gewarnt hat in
panik zu geraten war jetzt schon die
rede von chaos nächste rednerin in
dieser debatte ist bärbel bas seit
neuestem stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende der spd fraktion
meine damen und herren
erstmal möchte ich mich wirklich bei
allen bedanken die sich im moment mit
diesem corona virus beschäftigen das
sind zum einen die mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeiter im
bundesgesundheitsministerium und
natürlich die alle experten die rund um
die uhr
seit wochen jetzt daran arbeiten diese
diesen virus diese epidemie einzudämmen
und deshalb herzlichen dank dafür
die das jetzt machen insbesondere in die
richtung dass der pflegekräfte und der
mediziner unter medizinischen
einrichtungen
die stehen nämlich an der front und den
müssen wir helfen und das war sich
gerade gehört habt grenzt an
ahnungslosigkeit tut mir leid
vorbeigehen ich bitte sie wirklich
unterhalten sie sich mit ihren eigenen
kollegen aus dem gesundheitsausschuss
die von beginn an den telefonschalten
und vielen anderen sondersitzungen
beteiligt sind
die ausdrücklich noch am zwölften
zweiter dem minister und die regierung
gelobt haben für ihre aufklärungsarbeit
so und das können sie ja vielleicht
einfach mal zur kenntnis nehmen dass es
pandemiepläne geht wo all das was sie
bemängeln drinsteht dass wir uns mit den
ländern abstimmen und das wir
genau das führt in eurem tun und die
einzige die sich aus ihrem antrag mal
entnommen habe war mit wärmekameras zu
arbeiten also entschuldigung wenn ich
den virus übertragen kann ohne fieber
und symptomen zu haben warum soll ich
dann wärmekameras benutzen oder fieber
messen an flughäfen es macht keinen sinn
so und deshalb informieren sie sich
einfach und reden sie nichts und
fahrlässiger körperverletzung wenn sich
hier wirklich alle äußerste mühe geben
diesen corona virus zu einzudämmen
herauszuzögern und vor allen dingen
möglichkeiten zu erforschen am ende zu
einer impfung zu kommen und auch
therapien zu finden das ist jetzt unsere
aufgabe und das machen wir
und das jeden tag mit allen akteuren und
ich muss mir jetzt abgeordnet nicht an
alles zu wissen sondern wir sind auf
experten angewiesen wir sind doch
forscher angewiesen sondern auf die
sollten wir aufhören und das tun wir
auch und deshalb ist es ganz
entscheidend dass wir uns als politik
wir auch entscheiden wollen wir die
verunsicherung die da ist die will ich
nicht kleinreden die verunsicherung ist
da sowohl beim medizinischen personal
als bei jedem menschen da draußen auch
das kann man am klopapier erkennen es
ist überspitzt gesagt natürlich eine
große verunsicherung aber eine zahl will
ich enorme nennen wenn man hier von
fahrlässiger körperverletzung spricht
wir haben jetzt den früher schon 100.000
menschen die mit der influenza infiziert
sind
grippe und schon 1000 die gestorben sind
und bei dem corona virus bei dem was ich
gelernt habe von experten gibt es viele
die den virus vielleicht in sich tragen
aber sie sind weder krank noch haben
andere probleme und deshalb ist es
wichtig dass wir das medizinische
personal schützen dass wir für schutz
material sorgen die kritik müssen wir
uns anziehen und dafür sorgen wir jetzt
auch dass wir die dinge dass wenn
ausfuhrstopp haben dass es in zukunft
schutzkleidung gibt denn wichtig ist
dass die die mit kranken menschen
arbeiten pflegekräfte
medizinerinnen mediziner dass die
geschützt sind nämlich erstens selbst
damit sie uns nicht ausfallen und in
quarantäne müssen und vor allem damit
sie die menschen schützen de immun
geschwächt sind chronisch krank sind und
insofern dann auch beide seiten sicher
sind und dafür müssen wir jetzt sorgen
das war in der vergangenheit weil es
hamsterkäufe gegeben hat weil menschen
meinen sie müssten nur atemschutzmaske
haben
ich kann nur alle auffordern dass wir
ruhig bleiben es nicht ignorieren nicht
klein reden sondern dass wir damit
umgehen schritt für schritt und ich
setze auch darauf dass wir mit jedem tag
neue erkenntnisse über diesen virus
bekommen und dann auch mit forschern
zusammen gezielt handeln können wir
haben vielleicht nicht alle baustellen
sofort gelöst und ich glaube es wird
auch klar dass der föderalismus so die
ein oder andere schwierigkeit hat wenn
man nämlich über gesundheitsämter länder
und jeder unterschiedlich aufgestellt
ist und wir haben natürlich komme aus
einer stadt wie duisburg wenn man einen
gesundheitsamt hat wo einfach auch zu
wenig personal ist die gerade in so
einer situation gut ausgestattet sein
müssen werden wir uns sicherlich in
zukunft darüber unterhalten müssen wie
die gesundheitsämter vor ort die
behörden vor ort auch gut aufgestellt
sind in zukunft damit sollte sowas
wiederkommen oder sogar noch die zahlen
steigen werden dass sie gut ausgestattet
sind auch das müssen wir miteinander
klären weil einfach das die
überforderung großes 180 tausend anrufe
auf diese hotline gegeben so die müssen
bewältigt werden und dass der ein oder
mit seinem anruf nicht sofort durchkommt
ist auch verständlich deshalb muss man
das nicht überbewerten und ich finde wir
sind gut aufgestellt wir haben alles was
wir bis jetzt wissen umgesetzt und wir
werden auch dass da wo die baustellen
sind weiter umsetzen ich will den
gesundheitsminister unserem team dabei
auf jeden fall unterstützen herzlichen
dank dies sagt bärbel bas die
stellvertretende fraktionsvorsitzende
der spd fraktion nicht der redner ist
wie der fraktionsvorsitzender christian
lindner von den liberalen spricht jetzt
herr präsident meine kolleginnen und
kollegen kürzlich dachte man noch es
ginge darum das eindringen des virus
nach deutschland zu verhindern
jetzt gelten wir bis war ein selbst als
ein risiko land und das zeigt wie
schnell sich die lage verändert
deshalb verbietet sich jetzt eine schon
bilanzierende debatte und deshalb
begrüßen wir mit welcher klarheit
besonnenheit und transparenz die
bundesregierung mit dieser unsicheren
lage umgeht
es gibt große verunsicherung auch ängste
darüber ist schon hier gesprochen worden
das ziel muss jetzt sein der
gesundheitlichen schutz der bevölkerung
es geht um die information der menschen
und um das eindämmen des virus in einer
solchen situation verbietet sich für uns
jede parteipolitische kleinteilige
betrachtung diejenigen die jetzt für das
krisen management verantwortung tragen
verdienen im moment die ungeteilte
unterstützung dieses parlaments und vor
allen dingen verdienen diejenigen die in
heilberufen tätig sind unseren respekt
und dank und kein falsches störfeuer
der bundesminister für gesundheit hat
davon gesprochen dass die folgen der
krise und die angst möglicherweise
erheblicher sein könnten als das virus
selbst und das muss man ernst nehmen
in gesundheitlicher hinsicht werden wir
langfristig über konsequenzen nachdenken
müssen haben wir eigentlich die
richtigen schlussfolgerungen aus
früheren ereignissen gezogen
stimmt die behörden zusammenarbeit dazu
wird man kollege professor doktor med
android man gleich noch sprechen der
minister selbst hat gesagt er mache sich
notizen ersparen auch wir machen uns
notizen auf die man später zurückkommen
muss aber es geht eben nicht nur um
gesundheitliche risiken sondern es gibt
auch risiken in wirtschaftlicher
hinsicht die minister sparen und
seehofer haben ein krisenstab gebildet
wir erwarten dass es allen solchen
krisenstab auch von herrn altmaier und
herrn scholz gibt wo ist das
die oecd schlägt bereits alarm
wir wissen dass wir vor corona bereits
auf dem weg in eine rezession waren die
fed hat eine zinssenkung überraschend
beschlossen wo sind entsprechende
maßnahmen bei uns wir sind
nein gerade nicht sollte die ezb die
zinsen senken herr kollege
weil nämlich gleichzeitig angebot und
nachfrage ausfallen könnten und die
geldpolitischen möglichkeiten der ezb
bereits nahezu ausgeschöpft sind sind
fiskalische maßnahmen um so bedeutsamer
und da erwarten wir von der
bundesregierung einen plan
man darf doch nicht sehenden auges
dass die wirtschaft ab rauscht und wir
müssen jetzt handeln gerade weil wir als
exportnation durch die lieferketten und
die internationale einbindung in
besonderer weise verwundbar sind
herr schneider und deshalb erwarten wir
ein maßnahmepaket dass auch fiskalische
maßnahmen umfasst wir denken an
sonderabschreibungen bereits von der
großen koalition vorgesehene
entlastungen wo es also gar keinen
streit mehr gibt könnten vorgezogen
werden auch das wäre ein sinnvolles
signal staatliche investitionen können
beschleunigt werden den man kurzfristig
das planungsrecht und schlagt und vor
allen dingen gerade wenn es um den
kurzfristigen ausfall von produktionen
geht müssen die möglichkeiten der
kurzarbeit wieder flexibilisiert werden
damit sie praxistauglich sind bürger
bürger beschäftigte und betriebe
erwarten gemeinsam dass die regierung
sich den gesundheitlichen risiken stellt
aber in gleicher weise ist auch
notwendig den wirtschaftlichen risiken
etwas entgegenzusetzen dazu fordern wir
sie auf
die kollegen wirklich hilft meint lesung
kessler stellvertretender
fraktionsvorsitzender der
unionsfraktionen herr präsident meine
damen meine herren
die menschen sind schwer verunsichert
das liegt auch in einem gewissen maß an
der dauerbeschallung durch die mitte
ich will an der stelle ganz bewusst
sagen die medien spielen in dem
zusammenhang eine besondere rolle sie
haben eine antwort ung zu informieren
aber sie dürfen dieses thema meine damen
und herren nicht so überstrapazieren bis
es momentan tun das verunsichert die
menschen noch mehr und meine damen und
herren das misstrauen gegenüber kindern
spielt auch eine rolle in dem
zusammenhang die menschen sagen uns das
was china da macht an drastischen
maßnahmen
doch die wirtschaft gefährdet das wird
schon seinen grund
sie sagen die zahlen sind wahrscheinlich
gar nicht richtig die uns dabei richtig
berichtet werden
nein das meine damen und herren der
durchaus geeignet in deutschland noch
mehr verunsicherung noch mehr sorge
voran zu bringen und ich sage ihnen das
einzige was uns momentan davor bewahrt
ist das immense vertrauen der menschen
in unser gesundheitssystem und in die
handlung person und deshalb meine damen
und herren muss man diesen menschen an
der stelle ganz besonders danke für das
was sie täglich leisten und meine damen
und herren das was frau seidel vorhin
gesagt hat
das ist in letzter konsequenz eine
herabsetzung der leistung genau dieser
menschen die da täglich ihr bestes geben
bei ihnen heilig der zweck die mittel es
geht ihnen darum aus der situation
politisch kapital zu schlagen
das war auch ein kunde und ich kann
ihnen nur empfehlen orientieren sie sich
an den kollegen von der fdp die das ja
gerade wieder hinter gezeigt hat sehr
sachlich dargestellt haben alles und
lassen sie beim nächsten mal um gottes
willen ihre fachkollegen reden die haben
beim letzten mal sehr sehr satten die
arbeit der regierung gelobt natürlich
ändert sich die situation das ist ja
klar wir alle wissen nicht was passiert
was kommt und man muss diese maßnahmen
an der stelle auch tatsächlich anpassen
und glaube das ist unstrittig ich nenne
ihnen ein beispiel
mir geht es da insbesondere um die
rollen der arzt brach mir sagen ärzte
nicht nur wir bekommen kaum noch mal
sondern ist sagen die insbesondere wind
das meer wird dann machen wir dieser
plakate an die türen da steht drauf wer
glaubt corona zu haben bitte deutschen
und was passiert genau das nicht
die werden dann gehen die praxis ganz
normal sich ins wartezimmer setzen und
erst wenn sie bis zum arzt zu erziehen
vorgedrungen sind wenn sie sagen ich
glaube ich jap honda macht der dann also
einen rachenabstrich und wenn sich dann
herausstellt dass der richter hatte der
patient dann haben wir ein zusätzliches
problem weil dann die frage ist kann man
die arztpraxis so offen halten oder muss
man die nicht 14 tage oder vier wochen
schließen und deshalb
dass gesundheitsminister müssen wir wenn
es mehr wird über die frage nachdenken
ob nicht die gesundheitsämter diese
rolle übernehmen müssen der test und ich
glaube auch dass wir in der situation
jetzt dass wir in der situation jetzt
schon ganz besonders über den schutz
unseres medizinischen personals
nachdenken sie sich nur besonders
gefährdet sondern haben auch eine
besondere verantwortung eine besondere
rolle
und deshalb kann ich mir nicht
vorstellen dass es sinn macht einen
bundespflegegeld zu halten und sich hier
konzentriert zu versammeln und dann das
risiko zu haben dass da tausend schläge
kräfte ausfallen
ich glaube auch dass viele solche
zentralen veranstaltungen und
fortbildungsmaßnahmen in der jetzigen
situation tatsächlich hinterfragt werden
müssen
man darf nur dann eine krise ist immer
auch ein wendepunkt das gilt auch für
dieses coroner thema hier ich stelle
fest dass das thema persönliche hygiene
sowie dazu besonders wurden dass
gesundheitsminister angesprochen hat
mittlerweile bei den menschen eine
andere rolle spielt ich würde mir
wünschen dass das thema besucher hygiene
in den krankenhäusern in zukunft eine
neue eine andere rolle spielt da gibt es
zwar in jedem krankenhaus etwas wo man
sich die hände desinfizieren kann
aber es gibt keine schleusen wurde
besucher und ich glaube das sollte auch
mal darüber noch nachdenken so etwas
nicht nur wegen cholera sondern ganz
grundsätzlich auszubauen
kollege lindner hat sehr umfassend das
thema wirtschaft diskutiert es besteht
in der tat das risiko dass sich unsere
wirtschaft schneller infiziert dass die
menschen das muss man im blick haben
wir tun das aber auch da hat der
bundesgesundheitsminister einen
besonderen wendepunkt markiert es geht
um die frage insbesondere wo kommen die
grundstoffe für unsere medikamente
das ist etwas was mich runter wenn wir
da abhängig sind von china indien
südostasien staaten dann ist das etwas
was wir zu lange nicht im blick gehabt
haben was wir jetzt wirklich in den
fokus nehmen muss die verlagerung meine
damen und herren kamen nämlich auch
daher nicht aus rein ökonomischen
gesichtspunkten sondern weil dort die
umwelt entsprechend belastet wird wenn
du dich vorstellen dass jeden tag zwölf
milliarden liter abwasser in den ganges
laufen 3 50% davon übrigens unbehandelt
in china so ähnlich
dann sind die kostenvorteile von dem wir
profitieren umwelt bedient und schon und
deshalb dass wir das ganze nicht
zulassen und wir müssen solche
unabhängigkeit wiederherstellen wir
müssen uns da europäische anders
aufstellen
auch das muss eine lehre aus dem thema
corona sein
ich glaube dass das was sollte der
bundesgesundheitsminister geschrieben
hat und was in einem krisenstab zwischen
innenminister und gesundheitsminister
arbeit würde etwas ist was uns
tatsächlich hilft das thema corona im
griff zu halten aber wir alle wissen das
nicht zu beschreiben ist was davon steht
und deshalb ist es ganz wichtig dass die
politik die aufsicht die richtigen
maßnahmen ergreift und alles dafür tut
dass keine panik entsteht die afg hat es
an ihrem kopf schütteln ein offenkundig
anderes interesse findet sondern kehrt
nüßlein der stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende der unionsfraktion
hat hier auch nochmal die wirtschaft
angesprochen und gesagt die
bundesregierung denkt über verschiedene
maßnahmen nach noch sei es allerdings zu
früh für konkrete schritte
amira mohammed ali jetzt die
fraktionsvorsitzende der linken
sehr geehrter präsident der
gesundheitsminister kolleginnen und
kollegen wie ist die situation heute
durch das corona globus viele menschen
sind beunruhigt und ich kann das
verstehen
das muss man auch ernsten aber auch
unserer sicht aus sicht der experten des
robert koch institutes ist panik
vollkommen unangebracht
aber wenn aufgaben starke medien um ihre
verkaufszahlen und klickzahlen zu
erhöhen wenn die fast täglich mit neuen
panik schlagzeilen rund um corona kommen
dann werden angst und unsicherheit
geschürt aus furcht werden regale leer
gekauft ersparen sie haben auch in ihrer
rede eben sehr besonnen gesprochen und
das ist auch zu begrüßen
sie selber schüren diese panik nicht
aber die bundesregierung hat zu wenig
getan und tut nach wie vor zu wenig um
dieser medialen panikmache etwas
entgegenzusetzen
es gibt zu wenig sachliche informationen
sie haben gerade das gegenteil behaupte
der minister aber wenn man mit den
leuten spricht wenn man in die schulen
geht mit den lehrerinnen lehrern spricht
in den kindergarten mit den
kindergartenkindern bergmann spricht
dann berichten die davon dass sie sich
allein gelassen fühlen weil ich ihnen
vernünftige informationen fehlen sie
sind nicht sicher wie sie jetzt handeln
sollen und das geht nicht dieser zustand
muss dringend behoben werden
informationen müssen sofort anspringt
und die konsequenz dieser hamsterkäufen
die hier stattgefunden haben die ist ja
leider nicht nur dass man vielleicht
schwierigkeiten hat sich spontan nudeln
zuzubereiten wenn man keine mehr kriegen
haben sondern die ist die dass menschen
die schwere krankheiten haben ernsthafte
schwierigkeiten haben notwendige
desinfektionsmittel zu bekommen ich
kenne einen eltern ehepaar deren sohn
ist diabetiker und die haben wir davon
berichtet dass sie schwierigkeiten haben
die alkohol patch zu bekommen die man
braucht und insulin spritze verabreichen
zu können auch hier muss ich sagen
es wäre wichtig gewesen was die
bundesregierung rechtzeitig vorgesorgt
hätte das kam ja nun auch nicht ganz
überraschend wir haben ja gesehen dass
das virus zuerst in china aktiv war und
auch was die medien daraus gemacht haben
es war eigentlich abzusehen dass wenn
die krankheit deutschland erreicht das
dann auch hier panik entstehen wird das
heißt die bundesregierung hätte sich
rechtzeitig bevorraten müssen auch was
diese dinge angeht und natürlich hätte
die aufklärung viel früher erfolgen
müssen und transparenter gemacht werden
dass bei gesunden menschen in der regel
normale handhygiene ausreicht und man
die interessen aktions mittel gar nicht
benötigt und eine sache möchte ich auch
fragen warum ist es eigentlich so dass
müsste sich auch gar nicht so sein dass
es in diesem land was ja eigentlich sehr
fortschrittlich sein soll nicht bereits
heute der fall ist das an öffentlichen
orten die behörden bahnhöfen
fußballstadien warum gibt es da nicht
schon längst das infektions spende
das müsste doch längst der fall sein ich
weiß nicht warum sich darüber aufregen
frau kollegin ach so ich setzte die rede
ist von frau kollegen danke schön
ich bin der auffassung dass das machen
haben gewesen wären die man längst hätte
einleiten so haben wenn jemand freute
sehen würde dass sie das dass sie die
infektionsrisiken senken würden das ist
die realität und sie würden auch das
sicherheitsgefühl deutlich stärken und
wenn heute auch medien darüber berichten
dass menschen sich bevorraten sollen mit
lebensmittel das man bei 14 tage vorräte
anlegen soll
na da werden auch viele menschen
unsicher nämlich auch gerade die die
große schwierigkeiten haben sich
überhaupt mit lebensmitteln zu versorgen
wie sollen den menschen die heute sind
wir davon
wir brauchen sich bevorraten das geht
nicht wenn gesundheitsminister ich
erwarte von ihnen dass sie alle menschen
im blick haben wenn sie die notwendigen
schritte einleiten
und was man leider auch fürchten muss
und was man leider auch heute sieht ist
dass durch das corona virus situation im
gesundheitswesen die bereits jetzt nicht
gut ist durch die privatisierung bis das
kaputtsparen des besonders wesen das
erfolgt ist durch die große
belastungssituation der die erste
konzert für die pflegerinnen und pfleger
alle beschäftigen sind es lesen bereits
jetzt ausgesetzt werden dass sich das
weiter verschärfen sind und das sieht
man bereits heute
es ist unverantwortlich was da geschehen
ist und diese situation sollte wirklich
das endgültige alarmsignal dafür sein
dass das kaputtsparen im
gesundheitswesen ein ende haben muss die
gesundheitsversorgung gehört vollständig
in die öffentliche hand
und ja in der tat ersparen das haben sie
richtig angesprochen in ihrem beitrag
natürlich rächt sich jetzt auch dass wir
abhängig sind von den importen aus china
was schutzmasken angeht was
schutzkleidung angeht das begrüße sehr
dass sie das eingesehen haben das sagen
wir schon lange jetzt müssen auch
entsprechende taten folgen
und was ich jetzt auch recht oder bringe
zu rechnen droht ist die große akku
exportabhängigkeit der deutschen
wirtschaft die oecd hat gerade aufgrund
der aktuellen lage die diesjährige
wachstumsrate der weltwirtschaft auf 1 5
prozent halbiert der schlechteste wert
seit der finanzkrise 2009
und natürlich wird dass die deutsche
wirtschaft die ich sehr exportabhängig
ist extra hart treffen und für die
beschäftigten bedeutet das unter
umständen kurzarbeit lohnausfälle im
schlimmsten fall droht der
arbeitsplatzverlust und was wir nicht
brauchen sind die widersprüchlichen
antworten der großen koalition wie man
darauf jetzt reagieren soll
herr altmaier der sache kulturprogramme
sein strohfeuer
er möchte lieber steuergeschenke an die
konzerne verteilen herr scholz dagegen
sagt konjunkturprogramme sind sinnvoll
die mittel dafür stünden zur verfügung
lassen sie dieses typische groko theater
an dieser stelle bitte sein und agieren
sie besonnen und geschlossen wir
brauchen konkrete hilfsmittel und
initiativen für die beschäftigt und dazu
gehören auch garantierte lohnfortzahlung
den beschäftigten zu hause bleiben
müssen weil die kinder nicht zur schule
oder zur kita gehen können
wir linken wir appellieren da haben dass
die bundesregierung die richtigen
schlüsse auf diese situation zieht die
digitalisierung im gesundheitswesen muss
zurückgenommen werden und die
exportorientierung der deutschen
wirtschaft die muss auch um orientiert
werden denn das macht uns viel zu
anfällig für diese situation findet am
ihrer momentan die von der linksfraktion
hat hier ihre
rede gehalten unter deutlicher kritik
aus der grünen fraktion
diese kritik könnte jetzt auch
angesprochen werden kordula schulz-asche
spricht jetzt für bündnis 90 die grünen
[Musik]
herr präsident meine damen und herren
erlauben sie mir dass ich auch im namen
des ganzen hauses den menschen die
bereits erkrankt sind gute besserung
wünschen dass die menschen die in
quarantäne sind bald diese situation
verlassen können und lassen sie uns
gemeinsam danken den menschen die im
gesundheitswesen in heimen in arztpraxen
in krankenhäusern in den öffentlichen
gesundheitsämtern dafür kämpfen dass wir
es alle zusammen schaffen diese epidemie
aufzuhalten
die menschheit hat über jahrtausende
unter epidemien gelitten und war völlig
hilflos aber heute haben wir im umgang
mit infektionskrankheiten scharfe
schwert wir haben die wissenschaft wir
haben staatlich organisierten
infektionsschutz beginnt mit dem sehr
starken robert koch institut und seiner
wissenschaftlichen expertise bis runter
bis runter auf die gesundheitsämter da
komme ich noch mal drauf aber bis runter
auf die gesundheitsämter die sich lokal
im infektionsschutz für die bevölkerung
engagieren und wir haben impfungen auch
wenn wir bei carola jetzt noch keine
haben wir haben impfung die dafür sorgen
dass wir einen breiten schutz vor
infektionskrankheiten haben
und deswegen gibt es keinen grund zur
panik es gibt aber anders zu umfassender
vorsicht und zum handeln
das ziel im moment das kann sich immer
ändern aber das ziel
im moment heißt die schnelle ausbreitung
dieser epidemie zu verlangsamen zu
verhindern und das ist im moment das was
im vordergrund steht und aus dieser und
aus unserer sicht hat macht da im moment
die bundesregierung hier vieles richtig
wir haben jetzt besonnen
sie handelt wie sagte richtig und sie
handelt und darüber können wir uns auch
hier als mit ihr des bundestages nicht
beklagen sie handelt ausgesprochen
transparent über jede alle schritte sind
wir in der letzten zeit bestens
informiert wurden und wir wissen auch
dass die anderen akteure wie die
länderminister wie die gesundheitsämter
wie die anderen beteiligten stellen alle
genau wissen was der aktuelle stand ist
und was unternommen wurde
und es wäre es ist teil der panikmache
dass die eindruck erweckt würde man
hätte das alles viel früher machen
müssen
wir haben gesehen dass es in bayern mit
den mitteln unseres infektionsschutz es
gelungen ist diesen ersten diese erste
situation in den griff zu bekommen ohne
dass es andere infektionen gegeben hat
und seit der häufung in nordrhein
westfalen wo wir ihn nicht mehr genau
wissen wie der infektionsweg verlaufen
ist seitdem hat auch diese
bundesregierung alles richtig gemacht
sie hat den krisenstab einberufen
sie hat die aufklärung hochgefahren sie
hat die abstimmung zwischen ländern
kommunen und den gesundheitsämtern auch
mit der eu verstärkt und sie hat das lka
ganz stark in den fokus gestellt sowohl
zur information der bevölkerung als auch
zur begleitung dieser epidemie
der bundestag diskutiert hier über die
bekämpfung des corona virus gerade
kordula schulz asche von bündnis 90/die
grünen lobt hier die bundesregierung und
wir verlassen jetzt alle
links die debatte hier im bundestag weil
wir auch noch nach thüringen wollen um
1630 werden wir wieder kommen dann
diskutiert der bundestag über den
bundeswehreinsatz in afghanistan
bis dahin gebe ich nun aber erst einmal
ab zu meiner kollegin ina baltes im
studio in bonn
die tatsache dass er endlich kritischen
und die problematischen punkte im nicht
ausspart
die schwachstellen auch benennt das
fängt damit an dass natürlich
notfallpläne geübt werden müssen sonst
funktionieren sie nicht auf anhieb und
das ist in einer immer vergangenheit
vernachlässigt worden
dazu gehört dass man im
gesundheitsdienst den öffentlichen
gesundheitsdienst da sind übrigens alle
parteien daran beteiligt in den letzten
jahren nicht ausreichend personell
ausgestattet hat nicht ausreichend
finanziell ausgestattet hat und nicht
ausreichend mit verantwortung
ausgestattet hat dazu gehört der mangel
an fachkräften das ist ja schon
angesprochen und zwar im gesamten
gesundheitswesen und ganz besonders in
der professionelle pflege dass es der
bereich dir am meisten mit den
erkrankten menschen zu tun hat und der
einen besonderen schutz braucht und in
wir besondere aufmerksamkeit widmen
müssen und deswegen ist das thema
schutzausrüstung so unglaublich wichtig
es ist so unglaublich wichtig und auch
da möchte ich mich ausdrücklich bedanken
dass dieses thema der schutzausrüstung
von von gesundheitspersonal im fokus
steht ich freue mich dass halt heute
morgen auch wirklich aktiv angegangen
wird das sind alles sachen die müssen
erst hochgefahren werden
und da kann man nicht sagen dass die
regierung hier versagt hätte und ich
möchte an diejenigen appellieren die mit
hamsterkäufen oder sogar mit diebstahl
infektions mittel aus den krankenhäusern
stehlen was sind denn das für leute
wir haben es geht doch im moment nicht
um egoismus sondern es geht um
gemeinschaftliche solidarität man kann
infektion
krankheiten nur mit solidarität und
nicht mit einzelkämpfer gewesen
wir leben in einer globalisierten welt
und die tatsache dass viele arzneimittel
bestandteile fast nur noch in china
hergestellt werden ist tatsächlich ein
problem aber nicht erst seit korea
bekannt gerade für lebensnotwendige
medikamente für antibiotika für
impfstoffe brauchen wir eine europäische
produktion die bundesregierung wir
erwarten dass auch davon dass die
eu-präsidentschaft dass sie dazu genutzt
wird endlich wieder die lebenswichtigen
arzneimitteln in europa zu produzieren
damit solche fälle sich nicht
wiederholen
und wir brauchen auch hier ganz wichtig
eine internationale zusammenarbeit im
bereich der impfstoffproduktion und wir
haben ja angehört es im
haushaltsausschuss läuft parallel gerade
auch die aufstockung der finanzmittel in
diesem bereich ist können wir alles nur
begrüßen es kommt auf die zusammenarbeit
an es kommt auf unseren
gesellschaftlichen zusammenhalt an und
ich finde dass man tatsächlich jetzt ist
ja die interessen der bevölkerung in den
vordergrund stellen sollte und nicht
seine partie partikularinteressen als
partei oder als irgendwas
elisabeth mal ins studio
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
zuallererst ein herzliches dankeschön an
die mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter im
gesundheitswesen den ersten den
pflegekräften den labormediziner dem rk
ii und den zuständigen stellen dem bund
und land für ihr großes engagement
sie haben in den letzten wochen
herausragendes geleistet
täglich stündlich gibt es neue meldungen
über corner
mittlerweile sind standorte vormittag 10
uhr 240 fälle in deutschland erfasst und
beinahe alle bundesländer sind betroffen
und es ist in der tat eine ungewohnte
situation in der wir uns befinden und
gerade deshalb möchte ich in aller
deutlichkeit sagen werden können uns in
deutschland auf ein international im
internationalen vergleich gut
funktionierendes gesundheitssystem
stützen die band die pläne wurden
aktiviert und aktualisiert der
krisenstab tagt regelmäßig die aktuelle
lage wird kontinuierlich erfasst und
bewertet und daraus werden die
notwendigen handlungsempfehlungen für
die bevölkerung aber auch für das
medizinische und pflegerische personal
abgeleitet aber natürlich meine damen
und herren tauchen bei jeder epidemie
und wann gemüt immer wieder neue fragen
und herausforderungen auf wann und von
wem wird der protest bezahlt wie kommen
die notwendige schutzausrüstung in
ausreichender menge in die ambulante
praxis wer kommt für die kosten auf wenn
niedergelassene ärzte aufgaben vom
öffentlichen gesundheitsdienst
übernehmen
ich kann ihnen aber versichern alle
verantwortlichen stellen arbeiten mit
nachdruck daran diese fragen zu
beantworten und die probleme zu lösen
entscheiden
entscheidend ist es die infektionsketten
frühzeitig zu unterbrechen
die infektions ausbreitung zu
verlangsamen und dadurch zeit zu
gewinnen
zeit die wir brauchen und des virus und
seine eigenschaften besser
kennenzulernen zeit um risikogruppen zu
identifizieren und für diese
entsprechende schutzmaßnahmen anzuordnen
zeit um einen wirkstoff oder antivirale
medikamente zu entwickeln
meine kolleginnen und kollegen ich bin
keine infektiologen wie man nach redner
aber ich bin hausärzten und deshalb
möchte ich betonen dass neuartige corona
virus verursacht erkältungen
es handelt sich um eine klassische
atemwegserkrankung nach aktuellen
erkenntnissen ist die
infektionskrankheit bei der als ein
bisschen höher als bei der dritte aber
sehr viel sehr viel sehr viel niedriger
als bei masern und es ist mit einem
virus wie ebola überhaupt nicht zu
vergleichen über 80 prozent der
infektionen verlaufen sehr plante und
bei den 3 bis 5 prozent der erkrankten
mit schweren verläufen da handelt es
sich häufig um patienten mit
vorerkrankungen gibt die diese schweren
verläufe können auch tödlich enden
aber ich sage ihnen auch unsere
ärztinnen und ärzte und unsere unser
gesundheitssystem für die ist der umgang
mit atemwegserkrankungen und auch mit
schweren verlaufsformen keine neue
herausforderung wir können damit umgehen
deshalb denke ich eine vernünftige
grundeinstellung also weder leichtsinn
noch übermäßige furcht ist aus meiner
sicht das gebot der stunde
sensationsmeldungen und panik sind
völlig fehl am platz als
bundesgesetzgeber werden wir aus dem
aktuellen infektionsgeschehen und den
sich daraus ergebenden herausforderungen
viel darüber lernen wo unser
gesundheitssystem unser system des
gesundheitsschutzes der infektions
überwachung weiter nach postiert werden
muss der geht es um zuständigkeiten der
bundesweiten infektionen um meldeweg und
aufklärungsarbeit um die personelle und
sachliche ausstattung der zuständigen
stellen um beschaffen und bevorratung
von medikamenten und hier aus werden wir
notwendige gesetzgeberische maßnahmen
ableiten
jetzt heißt es aber erst einmal besonnen
und lösungsorientiert mit den aktuellen
infektionsgeschehen umzugehen lassen es
sehen uns daher sachlich und konstruktiv
und ohne polemik und panikmache
ich danke für die aufmerksamkeit an die
fdp
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident
liebe kolleginnen kollegen es gibt einen
grund zur sorge aber es gibt sicherlich
kein grund für panik oder hysterie
ich freue mich und bin auch explizit
dankbar dass die bundesregierung das
auch immer so äußert und bislang die
richtigen schritte getroffen haben
wir können nämlich gemeinsam die
ausbreitung von kurbelt 19 verlangsamen
werden wir das erreichen wollen meine
damen und herren müssen wir nur bereit
sein besonnen und nachhaltig zu agieren
sonst bleibt das problem unser jetziges
system ist darauf ausgelegt nur die
unmittelbar vergangene pandemie und
niemals die nächste zu bewältigen
das gefährliche ist das gefährde die
wirtschaftliche stabilität und kostet
kostet auch im schlimmsten fall auch
leben wir in deutschland und weltweit
müssen jetzt beginnen schritte zu
unternehmen um besser für die nächste
pandemie gewappnet zu sein denn ich sage
ganz klar dass corona virus ist kein
grund zur panik aber ist es ein
warnschuss
die jetzige situation zeigt uns dass wir
unzureichend auch wirklich schlimme
pandemien vorbereitet sind
damit meine ich nicht unbedingt uns in
deutschland auch wenn wir im global
security index nicht auf den
spitzenpositionen auftauchen
damit meine ich uns uns weltweit denn
das heißt dass corinna virus deutlich
gesundheit und ganz speziell wenn wir
ein virus real geht muss global agiert
werden und in deutschland sehen wir auch
einige probleme erstens die
kommunikation aufklärung sie war bisher
unzureichend denn in deutschland macht
sich panik breit die situation wird von
vielen menschen nicht richtig
eingeschätzt
von der ärztlichen basis erfahre ich
tagtäglich erfahre ich anrufe sms e
mails
wo die medizinische versorgung angst
steht die medizinische versorgung
unzureichend sein könnte oder die
fachliche kompetenz an ihre grenzen
kommt doch meine frage stellt sich
natürlich was würde passieren wesentlich
gefährlicheres virus auftritt denn zum
beispiel in krankenhäuser schwere fälle
zusätzlich zu bestehenden grippewelle
zusammen kommen auf die intensivstation
oder standard medikamente lieferengpässe
erfahre schlimmer werden
das sind die sorgen der menschen draußen
die regelversorgung die angst haben dass
die regelversorgung nicht funktioniert
es könnte tatsächlich eng werden wir
können etwas dagegen unternehmen
wir sollten auch zusammenstehen und auch
nicht die panik schüren sondern auch
erklären was passiert
daher fordere ich jetzt umgehend eine
offen und stramme kampagne als gegengift
gegen hamsterkäufe und panik wir müssen
auch eine stärkere praktische anwendung
anbindung der öffentliche
gesundheitsämter erreichen
für die zukunft in deutschland das ist
eine perspektive die noch und weiter
bitte wer müssen brauchen wir dringend
auch mehr infektions medizinische
kompetenzen also den facharzt für
infektiologie flächendeckend
mittelfristig müsse hubert koch dank
robert koch-instituts stärkeren
finanziell auch stärken
dazu brauchen wir auch in chief medical
officer der medizinische fachkompetenz
einer reformierten
bundessicherheitsrates einbringt und wir
sollen uns überlegen ob wir nicht eine
neue föderalismus debatte starten um
gesundheitlich kompetenzen zu bündeln
und die pandemische vorbereitung aus
einem bus zu erreichen
deshalb meine damen und herren kollegen
achten sie bitte auf die zeit präsident
wir müssen deshalb die kompetenz in der
bevölkerung stärken und müssen die
globale zusammenarbeit bei der
vermeidung von pandemien verbessern
herzlichen dank
das wort hat die kollegin karin maag für
die cdu csu fort frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen liebe kollegen zurück noch
mal zur strategie es ist ja im raum
gestellt worden da wären themen offen
unser klares strategisches ziel heißt
bis auf weiteres kontaktpersonen und
infektionen zu erkennen die
infektionsketten einzudämmen so dass
sich die viren möglichst langsam
verbreiten und es macht einen ganz
großen unterschied ob alle erkrankungen
innerhalb von vier wochen auftreten oder
eben in z
innerhalb von ein bis zwei jahren warum
macht das den unterschied weil die
eigenschaften des corona virus er
momentan noch nicht ausreichend bekannt
sind es ist umso wichtiger weltweit
krankheitsfälle zu beobachten zu
analysieren und zu bewerten
je mehr zeit gewinnen desto besser
können sich unsere wissenschaftler
unsere ärzte aber natürlich auch
verwaltung und politik
vorbereitungsmaßnahmen anpassen national
und international bis ich abstimmen
und ich bin und ich bin 19 minister
jeden spart außerordentlich dankbar dass
diese abstimmung auch initiiert und
betreut dass es sich kümmert und dann
auch handelt dann in der minister und
ich danke insbesondere an dieser stelle
auch bündnis 90 den und den grünen
bündnis 90 die grünen und auch der fdp
für konstruktive oppositionsarbeit das
ist nicht selbstverständlich wie wir das
bei anderen oppositionsparteien auch
seen vorbei
es wäre schön gewesen wenn sie ihre
fachpolitiker hätten reden lassen
es ist schwierig für mich ihnen
zuzuhören so wie sie mit der angst der
menschen umgehen dass es zynisch und vor
allem in bar jeglichen fachwissens und
ich finde es ärgerlich ausgesprochen
ärgerlich wenn ihr fraktionskollege
herrscht und das vorgehen des ministers
sei ausdrücklich seine gute
aufklärungsarbeit lobt ihm im namen der
ganzen fraktion sogar der afb gedankt
hat und sie das ganze so ignorieren und
ins lächerliche ziehen
da sollten sie sich besser ein beispiel
an einigen ihrer fraktionsmitglieder
nehmen und fragen bei ihnen geld auch
das wäre besser gewesen sie hätten ihre
fachpolitiker reden lassen harald
weinberg hat in der debatte vor einem
monat ebenfalls die gute
aufklärungsarbeit des ministers gelohnt
belohnt er sagt keine panik zu
verbreiten
wer richtig und gut gewesen und hat sich
an dieser stelle auch bedankt und liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen die
gesundheitsämter vor ort tun weiterhin
alles um dem auf dem auftrag einzudämmen
gerecht zu werden
aber nachdem nun die infektionsketten
und die kontaktpersonen teilweise nicht
mehr nachvollziehbar sind werden sich
die zahlen der infizierten geradezu
selbstverständlich auch weiter nach oben
bewegen
und genau so selbstverständlich und es
sehen bereits die entsprechenden company
pläne zb das lka aber auch der länder
der kommunen vor wo es die
bekämpfungsstrategie dann auch
schrittweise angepasst werden lokal auch
angepasst werden hin vom zum schutz der
schwächeren weg vom losen eindämmen
aber wichtig ist doch dass wir weiterhin
mit augenmaß arbeiten angepasst an die
jeweilige situation vor ort das
stichwort besonnenheit ist gefallen
vorsicht und vor allen dingen auf der
basis des fachwissens des robert koch
instituts und dann ist es richtig dass
zum beispiel entscheidung getroffen
werden über die absage von
großveranstaltungen oder schulschließung
aber das lokal getroffen werden die
behörden vor ort kennen die situation
und können das ganze sehr viel besser
einschätzen als wir von berlin aus und
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen bei allem
was in pandemieplänen und strategien
steht in echt betriebe vor ort bemerkt
man dann tatsächlich dass manches eben
noch nicht so gut funktioniert das gilt
es weder zu beschönigen noch zu
thematisieren
die handlungsempfehlung des rk ii aber
auch der kassenärztlichen
bundesvereinigung
zum umgang mit patienten laborleistungen
meldepflichten oder
abrechnungsmöglichkeiten sind angekommen
das wird zurückgespiegelt aber frau elli
entschuldigung frau metall ich werds
mehr merken das ist auch von ärzten
bestätigt worden wir kriegen auch diese
rückmeldung und das ist der unterschied
zur fach politik natürlich ist ihre ist
es regional unterschiedlich wir wissen
um die gegen presse bei dem
desinfektionsmittel oder den
schutzmasken insbesondere für die ärzte
und pflegekräfte
wir haben den apotheken jetzt ermöglicht
oder werden es ermöglichen dass sie
selbst wieder desinfektionsmittel
herstellen für einen begrenzten zeitraum
schutzmasken werden zentral beschafft
die ausfuhrbeschränkungen gelten mit
mittlerweile und dort wo es
abrechnungsfragen zu lösen sind haben
wir sie bereits gelöst
es wird weiterhin stolpersteine geben
das ist die botschaft vor allen dingen
an die leistungserbringer nennen sie uns
ihre probleme es ist in unserem
gemeinsamen interesse dass wir den
herausforderungen begegnen und corona
werden uns vor allem auch den blick auf
den medizinischen alltag nicht
verstellen entscheiden ist doch dass der
regelbetrieb in den praxen und
krankenhäuser und aufrechterhalten wird
da zum team vor allen dingen auch die
aufhebung die zeitweilige aufhebung der
pflegepersonal untergrenzen verordnung
von heute morgen das ist gut das ist
täglich für alle beteiligten wichtig im
nachgang herr lindner werden wir dann
bewerten was gut lief was falsch lief
was besser eingeübt werden muss es
bleibt der dank an alle die tag und
nacht im moment arbeiten an der
bekämpfung des corona in heroes danke
für ihren gewissenhaften und
angemessenen umgang und ihnen herzlichen
dank fürs zuhören
für die spd fraktion hat nun der kollege
sebastian hartmann das geht sehr geehrte
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen ich glaube weite teile der
heutigen debatte und auch viele der
beiträge und uns kolleginnen und
kollegen haben aufgezeigt wir sind
grundsätzlich gut vorbereitet und gehen
sehr differenziert und überlegt mit der
situation um in der wir uns befinden wir
haben notfallpläne
wir sind auf katastrophen situationen
vorbereitet und haben auch institutionen
die stark sind die in der lage sind zu
handeln das robert koch institut ist
angesprochen worden aber ich möchte auch
das bundesamt bevölkerungsschutz und
katastrophenhilfe erwähnen und ich
glaube jetzt vor der gemeinsamen
krisenstab von bund und ländern
eingerichtet ist dass wir zeigen dass
wir bereit sind zu handeln in dieser
stunde gerade in einem demokratischen
rechtsstaat ist es wichtig dass wir
informationen teilen und sehr
transparent vorgehen das haben alle
bürgerinnen und bürger selbst in der
hand sich zu informieren auf öffentlich
zugänglichen webseiten noch nicht dass
hereinzufallen was manche
unverantwortliche redebeiträge heute
hier versucht haben zu suggerieren dass
da ein geheimnis sei das etwas verdeckt
werden sollte sondern im gegenteil
liebe mitbürger mitbürger machen sie
dann auch gebraucht davon schauen sie
nach den notfallplanung und achten sie
darauf dass jede und jeder einen
entsprechenden beitrag leisten kann dass
wir gemeinsam diese krise bewältigen
können und uns allen ist klar dass wir
am anfang einer solchen herausforderung
stehen und noch lange nicht auf dem
hochpunkt sind oder gar am ende und es
sind 240 fälle davon 111 in nordrhein
westfalen und das bedeutet dass wir
jetzt diese ausbreitung verlangsamen
müssen wir müssen dafür sorgen dass es
eingedämmt wird
und damit sind wir bei einem punkt wo
jeder einzelne und jede von uns eine
verantwortung hat das heißt katastrophe
schutz
deutschland ist gut vorbereitet wenn
jede und jeder gut vorbereitet ist und
damit kann jeder in dieser situation
auch durch sein verantwortungsvolles
handeln dazu beitragen etwas zur
eindämmung zu tun etwas zum händewaschen
zur persönlichen hygiene
auch gesagt vor und die vorsorge und die
beachtung dieser hinweise das geht jeden
und jedem von uns an
es ist etwas merkwürdig in der situation
dass lange bekannte vorschläge zur
bevorratung gerade in privaten
haushalten was nudeln und reis angeht
nun plötzlich gezogen werden und wir vor
leeren regalen stehen
das ist in der situation wo doch wasser
und seife auch eine großartige chance
gerade was für die hygiene zu tun und
eben für die ausbreitung verhinderung zu
sorgen eine übertreibung wo ich aber
überhaupt kein verständnis habe liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen das muss man in
aller deutlichkeit sagen dass mancher
mitbürger auf die idee kommen in
krankenhäusern atemschutzmasken zu
klauen desinfektionsmittel und damit
denjenigen die am mitzunehmen die jeden
tag daran arbeiten nämlich pflegerinnen
und pfleger kranken helferinnen und
helfer aber auch ärztinnen und ärzte
dass diese handle me eingedämmt wird
da muss ein klares signal kommen das ist
kein solidarisches verhalten ist ein
widerspruch zu all dem was man jetzt tun
müsste und wir sollten das auch
ordentlich verurteilt liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen
wir sind vorbereitet weil wir auch
übungen durchgeführt haben und die seit
den 2000er jahren existierenden
pandemieplanung das ist ja gerade von
einer fraktion öffentlichen abrede
gestellt worden weiter zu verfallen
der 2007 an entsprechende
länderübergreifenden übung durchgeführt
und wir haben aus dieser übung auch
erkenntnisse nicht alles das muss man
auch die aussagen von dem was wir damals
erfahren haben gerade was föderalen
informationsfluss angeht haben wir
umgesetzt
nicht alles was wir an bevorratung
hätten vorhalten müssen ist in der form
eins zu eins umgesetzt worden
und wir werden uns genau anschauen
müssen wenn wir ein stück weiter
gegangen sind und auch in der
bewältigung in der nachschau sind ob
auch alle privaten vorsorge träger ihren
teil der verantwortung einem vollständig
durch ökonomisiert im gesundheitswesen
eingehalten habe denn es kann nicht sein
dass an dieser stelle ein
marktwirtschaftliches prinzip dazu führt
dass eben wichtiger als neue mittel über
wichtige vorsorge einrichtungen
entsprechend nicht ausgestattet oder
nicht bevorratet sind und das ist eine
verantwortung die wir als bund und
länder gemeinsam
auch die kommunen hier vor ort zu
unterstützen liebe kollegen
ich glaube in dieser situation kommt es
eben darauf an die nerven zu bewahren
dass wir gemeinsam handeln und ist ein
anderer stelle mal gesagt worden das
einzige was man wirklich fürchten muss
ist die furcht selbst
deswegen lassen wir uns nicht einreden
von denjenigen die eine solche situation
missbrauchen
das ist gerade von der rechten seite ich
hier im haus in unverantwortlicher weise
getan worden dass versucht worden ist
politischen geländegewinn mit
falschinformationen und verunsicherung
der bevölkerung zu machen es ist nicht
gelungen weite teile der rednerinnen und
redner haben das zurückgewiesen ist es
unverantwortlich im gegenteil es kommt
jetzt darauf an besonders sammeln und es
ist keine grenze zwischen opposition und
mehr tiere im haus erkennbarer vielen
teil
das ist gut so liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen für die cdu/csu-fraktion hat
nun der kollege dr mathias middelberg
das wort
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
liebe kolleginnen liebe kollegen ich
will mich der einschätzung des kollegen
hartmann ausdrücklich anschließen und
bedanke mich an dieser stelle für die
von fast fast allen beteiligten ihr
eingebrachte sachlichkeit und auch
differenziert hat in dieser debatte
ich finde das darf man an dieser stelle
bei diesem wirklich wichtigen thema das
und es wurde zu recht festgestellt wird
dass wir uns nicht parteipolitisch
auseinandersetzen sollten das darf man
an dieser stelle wohl feststellen
zentrale aufgabe für alle staatlichen
stellen aber auch für alle die wie wir
hier im haus verantwortung tragen ist es
jetzt die notwendigen maßnahmen zu
ergreifen angemessen zu kommunizieren
ohne unsicherheit und panik zu schüren
und deswegen möchte ich auch an dieser
stelle
stellvertretend für die zahlreichen
mitarbeiter und mitarbeiterinnen in
unserem gesundheitswesen auch noch
einmal unseren bundesgesundheitsminister
jens spahn ausdrücklich danken der von
beginn an in dieser angelegenheit klar
und zugleich besonnen agiert und
kommuniziert hat jens spahn und horst
seehofer haben einen gemeinsamen
krisenstab eingerichtet mit allen
betroffenen ressorts und auch die
bundesländer die dort eingebunden sind
auf viele der maßnahmen die dort
angesprochen wurden meldepflicht
quarantäne und anderes ist schon
eingegangen worden auch auf das
stichwort großveranstaltung so dass ich
speziell nur noch mal zu den punkten
sprechen muss die hier sag mal die
ordnungsbehördliche seite betreffen die
etwa kontrollen an den binnengrenzen
angehen wir nehmen solche kontrollen vor
im 30 kilometer- raum im rahmen
ohnehin stattfinden schleierfahndung und
im rahmen dieser schleier verhandlung
sind die bundespolizisten jetzt noch
einmal in besonderer weise
sensibilisiert worden im hinblick auf
anhaltspunkte für eine erkrankung mit
dem corona virus in diesen fällen sobald
das erkannt wird werden die örtlich
zuständigen gesundheitsbehörden
hinzugezogen diese nehmen dank
medizinische bewertungen vor
überlegungen hinsichtlich einer
vorübergehenden wiedereinführung
genereller binnen grenzkontrollen
unmittelbar an der grenze gibt es
derzeit nicht diese würden eine
ausbreitung des virus auch kaum
verhindern dass angesichts der
inkubationszeit nur bedingt möglich wäre
im grenzüberschreitenden verkehr von und
nach etwa china italien iran südkorea
und japan haben wir alle beförderer
verpflichtet ihre reisenden über das
virus zu informieren bei anhaltspunkten
für eine erkrankung werden die
entsprechenden gesundheitsbehörden
hinzugezogen
zudem haben wir flugreisende aus den
genannten betroffenen gebieten
verpflichtet auf aussteige karten
angaben zu ihrem flug sie am
aufenthaltsort zu machen das gleiche
gilt für den schiffsverkehr ich denke
das sind die angemessenen und richtigen
maßnahmen auch bei dem thema weitere
oder ungeordnete migration nach
deutschland handeln wir nach wie vor
zählen wir pro monat etwa 10.000
asylanträge in deutschland mit blick auf
diesen umstand hat das
bundesinnenministerium die bundesländer
gebeten sicherzustellen dass alle
schutzsuchenden personen über ihre
ankunft registriert werden im rahmen der
vorhandenen kapazitäten und vor dem
hintergrund ihres konkreten reise weges
bei der ohnehin stattfindenden
medizinischen untersuchung auch darauf
in augenschein genommen werden und
mittels eines geeigneten
es untersucht werden ob anhaltspunkte
für eine corona infektion erkennbar sind
diese maßnahme erfolgt ausdrücklich zu
dem zweck zu verhindern dass infizierte
personen in erst aufnahme einrichtungen
aufgenommen werden und dadurch eine
gefahr für die gesundheit der bewohner
dieser einrichtung und mitarbeiter
entsteht
ich glaube und das wurde ihr mehrfach
zum ausdruck gebracht dass diese
bundesregierung in
verantwortungsbewusster weise und
angemessene tätig ist und in dieser art
und weise und in dieser angemessenheit
sollten wir weiter verfahren herzlichen
dank
das wort hat der kollege rudolf henke
für die cdu csu fraktion
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen meine damen und herren ich will
vier bemerkungen machen und leider dreht
sich die erste bemerkung doch noch mal
um die frage aus welcher motivationslage
heraus übernehmen sie das frau beide für
die fdp-fraktion hier zu sprechen und
lassen es nicht ihre kollegen aus dem
gesundheitsausschuss machen
dafür habe ich zwei mögliche erklärungen
entweder sie sind zu dem ergebnis
gekommen dass die relativ sachliche
auseinandersetzung ihrer kollegen im
gesundheitsausschuss schleimerei ist
gegenüber dem gesundheitsminister
gegenüber der koalition gegenüber den
anderen kollegen
ich glaube das nicht oder sie sehen in
dieser krise eine weitere chance dafür
diese gesellschaft zu spalten sie sehen
eine chance diese krise die wir gekommen
sind als ein instrument für
parteipolitischen vorteil zu nutzen
und ich glaube dass das so ist weil ihre
äußerungen im netz ja noch viel schärfer
sind als die die sie hier vortragen wenn
ich etwa auf ihren post gucken wo sie
behaupten die sterblichkeitsrate beim
corona virus ist zehnmal höher als bei
einer normalen grippe
woher wissen sie das das weiß gar keiner
sie ist etwas höher als bei der gruppe
aber zehn mal höher ist eine freche
behauptung die durch keine fakten belegt
ist und wenn sie sagen die regierung
unter
nichts um die risiken für die
bevölkerung zu minimieren dann liegen
sie damit die bevölkerung schlicht und
ergreifend an und warum können sie da
ein interesse daran haben weil sie auch
bei diesem thema spalten wollen und
deswegen muss ich sagen wünsche ich mir
eine rückkehr ihrer fraktion zu der form
der debatte die im gesundheitsausschuss
natürlich auch kontrovers geführt worden
ist
der zweite punkt ja ist ein einzelfall
aber es ist ein einzelfall immer ja dann
auch mal anerkennen
das zweite die zweite bemerkung die ich
machen möchte
ich möchte schon noch einmal darauf
hinweisen in der bevölkerung was kann
man tun ich tue das auch deswegen weil
ich als präsident der ärztekammer
nordrhein
von vielen kolleginnen und kollegen höre
unter welchem druck sie bei uns im
rheinland zurzeit stehen weil wir
versuchen freiwillige hilfe zu
organisieren mit denen wir die
kolleginnen dem kreis heinsberg in
gangelt in erkelenz unterstützen können
und weil ich weiß wie schwierig das ist
die abläufe genau zu verstehen
jeder kann sich selbst fragen habe ich
grippeähnliche symptome fieber husten
atemnot uns war ich in den letzten 14
tagen in einem risikogebiet kann man
beim rk je nach gucken welche
risikogebiete oder hatte ich innerhalb
der letzten 14 tage kontakt zu einem
corona virus erkrankten und in diesen
fällen wenn man das alles mit ja
beantwortet dann ist eine abklärung
nötig und dabei gilt erstens
telefonischer kontakt zum hausarzt oder
zu der 116 117 aber eben telefonischer
kontakt und nicht hin rennen und nicht
die wege und die notfallambulanzen
verstopfen
zweitens händehygiene einhalten was
gründliches waschen der hände mit wasser
und seife über 20 sekunden beinhaltet
niesen husten in die armbeuge oder in
einweg taschentücher und die möglichst
in einen mülleimer mit deckel entsorgen
und möglichkeit ein bis zwei meter
abstand
zu husten oder niesen personen halten
und damit habe ich wesentlichen schutz
hergestellt und sich ins gesicht packe
die eintrittspforte per se für diese
viruserkrankungen sind die augen
deswegen nutzt es auch nichts mit den
masken durch die gegend zu laufen
sondern die augen sind die
eintrittspforte und das schlimmste was
man machen kann ist mit fingern wo man
überall hin getan statt sich
anschließend ins gesicht zu packen und
wie tränen wegzuwischen oder in die
augen zu
das muss man auch seinen kindern
beibringen
und deswegen glaube ich hat der einzelne
viele möglichkeiten einzudämmen und die
letzte kommen ja gar nicht zu vier
bemerkungen weil die zeit dann schon um
ist und die letzte bemerkung die ich
machen möchte
ja es wird so sein dass wir natürlich
eine steigende anzahl infizierter haben
werden aber dafür haben wir eine
strategie und diese strategie besteht
jetzt aus dem möglichst starken
eindämmen der ausbreitung und zweitens
in der produktion von denen die
besonders wohl gerade sind und drittens
in der abmilderung der folgewirkungen
das nennt das lka etwas englisch
formuliert kollege handy ja ich komme
zum ende containments protection
mitigation und deswegen vor weise ist
die ansage dass die regierungen oder das
lka keine strategie hätte eine bloße
pure falsche verunsicherung der
bevölkerung und bitte lassen sie das in
zukunft bleiben
vielen dank für die aufmerksamkeit ich
schließe die aussprache